foreign
discussion so let's play this Instagram
reel in 16 years your daughter will not
be able to buy a house it will not be
affordable for her to buy a house unless
you help her I would argue that it is a
Better Business decision it is a better
financial decision for you to buy a
house for her it's an investment
property it's a rental property all of
the money that comes from that goes into
an account and that is her College
number one and number two that house is
being paid for by somebody else so then
when she is 22 years old graduated from
college you can say your sweetheart here
is the home that you will never ever
have been able to afford if I had not
bought it for you 16 years ago and I'm
telling you right now that is the best
financial decision rather than going to
529 whatever that thing is college fund
that is oh yeah complete and total
bullet I agree with that I'm telling you
right now going ahead and buying a house
as an investment that is the best thing
that you can do for your children and
I'm not selling anything I own because I
wish I'd kept everything I ever bought
yeah wow a lot there fascinating she was
a bit of a machine gun there she knew
what she wanted to all right come over
to the world
um myth number one first thing she said
that's incorrect and it's just absolute
emotional hyperbole is that your
daughter won't be able to buy a house it
won't be affordable
on her own that's fear mongering and
that's that's kind of playing into this
whole you know uh upper class versus
lower class that's a little bit of
middle class Warfare because she's
making a point uh but that's exaggerated
and it's not true secondly
um what she's prescribing there is most
likely I don't have any other context
you know this person nope nope I don't
have any other context but she's
probably saying take on debt so let's
say an American family's got a bunch of
debt and then they were to take what she
were to say is Gospel proof now they're
going to go get a second mortgage and
under the guise of well this is really
really smart so it's incomplete advice
so there's two things things right out
of the game okay so number one yes I'm
with you on the fear thing I'm like no
that's just not I just I just am not
yeah I don't agree uh number two yes
getting on that second mortgage where
I'm like man now if you ever pay cash
for it that's a different discussion but
people think in the like the real estate
and yeah but people think with real
estate they're like oh yeah it's you
know you just buy it and someone else
will pay the mortgage and it's no big
deal yeah it's a part-time job when you
have other properties like and risky and
risky because what if you don't have
anyone to fill it and then who's gonna
pay the mortgage so uh third thing the
529 is a wonderful investment vehicle
she makes it out like it's some sort of
piece of crap and they're both like oh
yeah 529 it's so stupid well if it's not
that's not right 529 is a wonderful
investment vehicle and it can be used
multiple ways so you know again the the
poo pooing what's normal and the fear
mongering here this is incomplete
however all right those are three things
I didn't like okay give me what you did
like Kenneth here's the caveat all right
right the caveat is
if you have no debt all right you have
no debt the Ramsay way
and you can put a sizable down payment
on a home a future home
and in in the in the context of what
she's saying for your child versus
fund their college
I don't think that's foolish and I only
say that to say you have to be
financially responsible like this is not
stressing you out financially you can
put a huge down payment on it so you're
going the amount of money I would put
towards their college is more than a 20
down payment
and we have no other debt therefore this
is not stressing us out
um in that situation it is a very
interesting idea because college has
increasingly got more expensive and less
relevant and that is true yes so you're
giving your kids some options to where
they could cash flow their way through
college with the rent is what she's
saying that's right well oh no they just
they work and so you've now given them
this long-term investment you've gifted
them this long-term investment it's
interesting I'm not recommending it or
endorsing it right but I at least want
to be an equal opportunity commenter
if you have the financial wherewithal
and you're not going at any kind of risk
and you're not assuming a very large
amount of debt right uh it's not it's
not a it's not a horrible idea but the
way they set it up is an incomplete
narrative yes that's a that's a great
way of putting it that's fair because
too I'm like when you transfer an asset
like a house there's a lot of things you
were talking about this earlier yeah you
got it there's like a tax there could be
tax implications if you're not careful
all this and and the rental income that
you make is taxable like it's just yeah
all of this and I'm like man
I don't know it's just
I I don't know why I'm like it just it
feels uh like get an upma or something
like like start investing and this is
the nature of social media people like
this can sway people with an incomplete
narrative and what you need to
understand is is that you're assuming
risk and you can't guarantee that you're
gonna have renters all the time there's
a lot of things that are that are at
play versus the 529 can be used in a
variety of ways towards qualifying them
so if they don't go to traditional
College they can still use the 529 for a
trade school which now is like you know
it can be past try to different children
all that so what yeah but college is it
is a fascinating topic right now because
there's a part of me though that I still
am like that transition from 18 to 21
still having a level of responsibility
still learning and growing like that
that is a I want to challenge you I know
I know but listen listen like that still
there is there is prose to that there
are but my question is my my is like
what is college going to look like in 15
years and I'm putting money in a 529
very different so what what is it going
to look like and I don't think you're
gonna be nervous too yeah I get that hey
I got to tell you this yesterday Entre
leadership Master Series happening
downtown Nashville I took a question
from a business owner that operate big
like Pacos and big giant tractors and
things like that on construction sites
they're hiring kids straight out of high
school to operate these big machines I
mean kids are loving it they're making
as much as 55 60 000 pretty awesome
right out of high school